the city is in chaos we must turn the  tide here though when calling me to you  this place yet here we are standing  round face to face the time has come to  show for being one where all you thought  you coming undone is that you reaching  all you wanting to run stand down or  showdown baby  done  we could be pistol  don't run down  we may be different  with different skills but when the world  is darkest we fight for the same cause  you look at me  for we are stronger as a brother  together we could be  this is the  make history Assassin's Creed unity  pre-order now for two bonus offers the  PIA team spend a win game get a chance  to win prizes every Friday and the  explosive chemical revolution mission  pre-order now